book is rule number two in it she
reflects on treating Marines while
serving in a combat hospital in Iraq
this is 35 minutes I hope you found the
crab cakes delicious that we are very
proud of our crab cakes here at the
University Club again thank you all for
being here this afternoon it's a real
pleasure for me to introduce our excuse
me our guest speaker I've known her for
a while before she even got married her
father-in-law and I first met in 1953
I'm only about 54 years old but that's
alright
Ron Kraft and so I've known Heidi and
her husband Mike for many years and
watch Mike grow up through the Naval
Academy in the Marine Corps hire heidi
Squire craft received her PhD in
clinical psychology from the University
of California at San Diego in 1996 after
several years as a flight psychologist
with the US Navy she gave birth to twins
in 2002 Brian and Megan and their
beautiful little children who make their
grandparents very very excited and they
enjoy very much
in February 2004 she deployed to Iraq
for seven months
she left active duty in March 2005 after
nine years in the Navy and is now deputy
program coordinator u.s. Navy combat
stress control heíd he lives in San
Diego with Mike and with her two
children please let me introduce to you
dr. Heidi Squire craft
[Applause]
good afternoon thank you so much Leo I
really appreciate that it has been a
real pleasure to be here at the
University Club thank you to everyone I
was looking around for all the people
who made this event possible everyone
has been so terrific to work with and
it's really been a pleasure to be here
thank you especially to Leo lawless who
introduced me not only for the wonderful
introduction but for arranging this
invitation for me to be with you today
to be honest you are the absolutely the
first group to which I will speak about
rule number two this is the first and
the last book that I will write not
because the last year hasn't been an
incredible amount of fun and rewarding
and very very exciting but simply
because I am a clinical psychologist who
never intended to be an author I
deployed as Leo said with a Marine Corps
surgical company to Iraq in February of
2004 at the time I was an active duty
Navy clinical psychologist based out of
Naval Hospital Jacksonville Florida and
my boy girl twins at the time were 15
months old
of course at that moment it was
extremely difficult to leave what mother
doesn't find that to be an incredible
challenge but I had joined the military
with the knowledge that when I put on
the Navy uniform that we deploy to care
for the marine corps during times of war
I knew that it was what I joined to do I
also knew it from my family and in my
heart as Leo mentioned my husband a
Naval Academy graduate and a Marine
Corps harrier pilot in addition my
father also a Naval Academy graduate and
in a career submarine officer so I
suppose it was always in my blood I said
goodbye to my family and I headed to
Camp Pendleton the Marine Corps Base in
California for several weeks of training
with a medic
battalion there before we left together
then we flew halfway across the world
through Kuwait to a place called Al Asad
Air Base in western Iraq this was a
former Iraqi Air Force Base and it had a
very long runway so the Marines decided
this was the place to set up their Air
Wing the US Army was leaving the base as
we arrived so our job was to set up a
mobile field hospital amazingly
similarly to mash the TV show even as
many years later to care and provide
assistance to the Marines operating in
that area I was part of a four-person
combat stress platoon two docks and two
psychiatric technicians and together we
were responsible for the mental health
care and treatment of 10,000 Marines in
western Iraq in the AL Ambar province of
Iraq toward the end of that seven-month
deployment which you all remember 2004
especially April of 2004 this was a
difficult seven months for us as medical
personnel I decided to write a list of
things that were good and bad about our
deployment and of course this was a
source of great entertainment for the
people that I deployed with because they
thought that's going to be a pretty
lopsided list but I decided to do it
anyway
it was for me at that moment something
that was needed it was it was therapy it
was my own way of starting to process
the experience it ended up taking on
oddly the form of a poem of sorts and I
sent it via email to my husband I had
been sending him updates through email
the entire time and he had been
forwarding those things on to a group of
about 25 family and friends the poem
mm-hmm through the power of our beloved
Internet was forwarded literally around
the world
so by the time I returned to Florida the
list which is what I called it had made
its way to literally around the world
and to many different parts of life both
military and civilian leading to
multiple requests for permission to
reprint it as well as requests for
interviews at first especially upon
returning home I found the attention to
be pretty overwhelming and even
embarrassing but then the email started
coming in and they were emails from
Vietnam and Korea and World War two vets
Marines and Navy corpsman and nurses and
they told me that the poem made them cry
and then my attitude changed and I was
humbled one of those Vietnam Marines a
retired lieutenant colonel and Pulitzer
Prize nominated author otto lyric
contacted me and he convinced me that
the experiences in the poem needed to be
expanded in written form for some reason
still unclear on that I decided to go
ahead and start writing it's sort of a
big time and Otto agreed to help me
I never at that point had any intention
or even vague thought of publishing this
I wrote it as therapy and interestingly
writing of traumatic experiences has now
become a very established and accepted
form of therapy in order to treat PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder at the
time I just wasn't really aware that
that's what I was doing so I wrote these
stories not only to process my own
feelings but also as a record for my
children I returned home just before
their second birthday and they had
changed from babies to toddlers of
course with no memory whatsoever of mom
in the desert so I wanted them to have
that one year
250 pages later Auto passed me on to his
literary agent also a former Marine who
convinced me to move forward with
submission to publishing houses today I
feel very fortunate to be working with
little brown and company and I'm very
excited at last for the publication of
rule number 2 in October in thinking
about the way to speak to you today I
decided that it was pretty important
actually to share the poem since it did
start at all and it is the foundation on
which the book was built while I read it
I'll have some pictures going here
I hope sunset over the desert almost
always orange sunrise over the desert
almost always red the childlike
excitement of having fresh fruit at
dinner after going weeks without it I'm
sorry this starts with things that were
good I've know this so well that I
almost forget things that we're good
these are the things that were good
being allowed to be the kind of
clinician I know I can be and want to be
with no limits placed and no doubts
expressed but most of all the United
States Marines are patients walking
every day and having literally every
single person who passed say hoorah
man having them tell us one after
another through blinding pain or
morphine induced euphoria when can I get
out of here I just want to get back to
my unit meeting a young sergeant who
lost his eye in an explosion he asked
his surgeon if he could open the other
one and when he did he sat up and looked
at the young Marines from his fire team
who were being treated for superficial
shrapnel wounds he smiled laid back down
and said I only have one good eye doc
but I can see that my Marines are ok and
of course meeting the one I will never
forget the one who threw himself on a
grenade to save the men at his side who
will likely be the first Medal of Honor
recipient in over 11 years
my friends some of them are lifelong in
a way that is indescribable my patients
some of them had courage unlike anything
I had ever experienced before my
comrades at Alfa surgical company some
of the things witnessed will traumatize
them forever but they provided
outstanding care to those Marines day in
and day out sometimes for days at a time
with no break for seven endless months
and finally above all else holding the
hand of that dying marine things that
were not good
terrifying camel spiders poisonous
scorpions flapping bats in the darkness
territorial wild dogs flies that
insisted on landing on our faces
giant looming mosquitoes invisible sand
flies that carry leishmaniasis 132
degrees wearing long sleeves full pants
and combat boots in 132 degrees random
and totally predictable power outages
that led to sweating throughout the
night sweating in places I didn't know I
could sweat like wrists and ears the
roar of helicopters overhead the
resounding thud of exploding artillery
in the distance the popping of gunfire
not knowing if any of the above sounds
is a good thing or a bad thing the siren
and the inevitable big voice telling us
to take cover not knowing if that siren
was on someone's DVD or if the big voice
would soon follow the cracking sound of
giant artillery rounds splitting open
against rock and dirt the rumble of the
ground the shattering of the windows
hiding under flak jackets and Kevlar
helmets away from the broken windows
waiting to be told that we could come to
the hospital to treat those that were
not so lucky watching the black
helicopter with the big Red Cross
landing at our pad worse watching
gray marine helicopters full of patients
landing at our pad because we usually
did not realize they were coming
assuring a sobbing Marine colonel away
from the trauma Bay where several of his
Marines bled and cried out in pain
inside meeting a 21 year old corporal
with three purple hearts and listening
to him weep because he felt ashamed of
being afraid to go back telling a room
of stunned Marines and blood-soaked
uniforms that their comrade that they
had tried to save had just died of his
wounds trying as if in total futility to
do anything I could to ease the trauma
of group after group that suffered loss
after loss grief after inconsolable
grief washing blood off the boots of one
of our young nurses while she told me
about the one who bled out in the trauma
Bay and then the one she had to tell
when he pleaded for the truth that his
best friend didn't make it
listening to another of our year nurses
tell of the Marine who came in talking
telling her his name about how she
pleaded with him not to give up told him
she was there for him about how she
could see his eyes go dull when he
couldn't fight any longer and finally
above all else holding the hand of that
dying marine the dying marine to whom I
refer in the poem is corporal Jason
Dunham in January of this year I was
invited by his father and mother to
attend the White House ceremony where
President Bush posthumously awarded the
Congressional Medal of Honor
to corporal Dunham Jason Dunham in
jumping on a grenade gave his life to
save the people on his fire team the
Marines and sailors with whom I had the
privilege to serve in Iraq had that same
spirit the raw courage and undying
commitment to one another
that spirit was the inspiration for rule
number two
it's the reason I wrote it it's the
reason I went forward to try to have it
published and it's the reason I stand
before you today it's a common theme
throughout the book these stories
provide a unique window for people who
have not been in Iraq to understand just
a little bit about the type of people
that are fighting for us out there it is
also a common theme in the two short
chapters which I've chosen to read for
you from the book today
the story is alluded to in the poem it's
called one good eye an urgent call
crackled through the speaker on my
handheld radio triage request for combat
stress
this meant possible cut side
psychological intervention for
casualties when I arrived I found our
sick call very busy with less seriously
wounded patients filling exam rooms and
spilling into the passageway in the
center of the activity bill one of our
physician assistants looked calm let's
get these guys cleaned up he told one of
the corpsman who guided three Marines
and blood-stained uniforms to a cleared
area in the passageway and seated them
on cots each had been hit with shrapnel
in his arms legs or face but all three
were walking and talking bill
acknowledged me with a smile as he
hurried back to an exam room the power
was out across the base and the hospital
felt like a sauna
except of course the o.r the ward and
the lab where the backup generators ran
tiny window air-conditioning units
Bill's blouse was off and sweat darkened
his green t-shirt and glistened off the
9-millimeter pistol hanging over his
shoulders and a leather holster ie D I
asked yep just those three in there no
their sergeants in here he motioned
toward the open door his hands full of
supplies he lowered his voice and leaned
towards me he lost his eye in the
explosion the lid is intact but the eye
itself is gone except for the single
blood black rod which maybe the optic
nerve I followed him into the exam room
where a stocky marine with dark hair lay
on the makeshift table his slightly
deformed left eyelid and superficial
lacerations on his cheek and chin would
never have suggested that the eye
underneath was missing he moaned as bill
opened with his lid with gloved hands
the okay sergeant bill asked him I'm
just taking the look here real quick
sure the patient said quietly biting his
lip I drew in my breath when I saw what
was under his eyelid a thin dark stem of
tissue protruded from the gaping empty
socket
would be sent via urgent medevac to
Baghdad to see an ophthalmologist if it
involved life limb or eyesight the helo
was here in 30 minutes amazing huh bill
whispered I nodded as we looked at each
other
just then the Marine grabbed Bill's
wrist hey Doc he asked what's up
sergeant my eyes not gonna make it is it
I'm not gonna lie to you it's not good
bill answered carefully my mom's gonna
kill me the patient joked with a wry
grin bill and I smiled - hey doc yes is
my other eye okay it looks that way to
me can I open it sure bill said let me
just get something to patch the injured
one first though okay he motioned for
one of the corpsman who moved in to
place gauze and medical tape over the
mutilated eye the Marine asked for help
to sit up opened his intact eye and
scanned the passageway he recognized the
members of his fireteam who by now had
their shirts off and were having their
wounds dressed he silently counted them
he sighed with a smile and gingerly
lowered himself back to the cot thanks
doc he said closing his eye I only have
one good eye but I can see that my
Marines are okay
and the second chapter I've chosen is
called woman's best friend sometimes
when a black hawk with its bright Red
Cross landed on our pad and swirl of
dust the patient brought in on the
gurney was not a Marine sailor soldier
or even an enemy prisoner of war
sometimes the patient was a dog the
Marines had a large Corps of working
dogs beautiful sinewy shepherds who
aided the mission in Iraq through the
detection of explosives weapons and bad
guys each dog had a Marine handler and
hundreds of these duo's were spread
throughout the country the good news was
the dogs were treated like royalty with
guaranteed air-conditioned spaces and
great food the bad news was sometimes
they needed a doctor our veterinarian
was Army Major Tim lunin an extroverted
man with a warm engaging grin who had
once been a paratrooper sharing
resources with our operating room an
intensive care unit allowed Tim to build
a complete animal surgical suite in the
basement of the hospital he knew of my
fondness for dogs so he sent word to me
whenever he had a quote lover a working
dog that adored being adored not all of
them fit this category by the way
whenever a lover arrived at Tim's shop I
found a way to spend some time in the
basement talking to the gorgeous animal
while I stroked his head and kissed the
bridge of his long nose in Iraq I
developed a new appreciation for pet
therapy I believe Tim knew how happy I
was to have this unique opportunity to
escape the desert for a few magical
moments with his canine charges but I do
not believe I ever told him how much I
appreciated his role in saving one of my
patients lives sergeant sergeant
Hutchison and I should say all the
patients names and identities are
changed in this book
sergeant Hutchison a petite petite
brunette with Frankel's freckles
sprinkled across her nose was a
helicopter flight equipment specialist
like many marine pilots and aircraft
maintenance personnel she found herself
in Iraq filling an unfamiliar role in
her
as a member of an auxilary Support
Battalion grueling to convoy duty took
its toll on everyone in her company but
sergeant Hutchison had two other
problems in addition to fatigue and
vulnerability she had a history of
clinical depression and she was the only
woman in her company she came to me
early in the deployment feeling
lethargic weepy hopeless and fleetingly
suicidal the sergeant and I had a
heart-to-heart she did not want to be
sent home through tears she begged to
stay although she worried about how she
would succeed she said she wanted to
finish the deployment to prove to both
her unit and herself that she could I
believed her Jason and I worked together
combining antidepressant medication and
intensive therapy to teach her to block
her self-defeating thought processes for
a while she made progress and slowly
experienced more energy and self-worth
halfway through the summer the sergeant
experienced the loss of one of her
friends in an IUD explosion this caused
a downward spiral in her functioning
that I feared pointed to her medevac she
told me her future was hopeless she
spoke of falling asleep and never
awakening she and I worked long into the
evening that day and I could almost hear
her fingernails digging in as she
struggled to maintain her grip on mental
health she held on the operational tempo
of her unit increased and she was unable
to see me for almost two months
and then one day four weeks before we
returned home sergeant Hutchison strode
into our office a different woman her
hair was pulled back her cheeks were
rosy and I think I saw a trace of lip
gloss
she smiled brightly I had never seen her
smile before our unit has adopted this
puppy she started as she sat down I had
heard about several groups of Marines
finding the orphaned puppies of wild
dogs on base and making them unofficial
mascots feeding them with shipments of
puppy chow sent from home everybody
liked him but he always came to me he
sort of became mine anyway I heard some
people were sending their puppies home
my heart sank a little immediately
worried that my sensitive patient would
be devastated if her plan did not
succeed so I came to talk to major lunin
I smiled proud of her initiative
he's mice isn't he Oh ma'am he's so nice
she gushed he took a look at Koko that's
what I'm calling him because he looks
like the color of chocolate anyway he
gave him all his shots and did the
operation to neuter him and he did the
worm medication to major Lunan says he's
in great health I had to admit I was
surprised Tim would not have gone to all
that trouble if there was no chance of
this woman being able to keep this dog
would he he said he had a friend in
Kuwait who would keep cocoa for the six
week quarantine thing he said I just
need to arrange to have cocoa sent to
Kuwait so I went and talked to the c-130
squadron and they said sure they take
him patients rarely truly surprised me i
sat and stared at her
so koko got to Kuwait major Lunan told
me and the vet there did all the customs
paperwork and all that was left was an
airline ticket so my mom and dad got
that and they picked him up at the
Detroit Airport yesterday they're gonna
bring him to San Diego for me when we
get home she sat back in her chair
crossed her arms over her chest and
grinned Wow
I shook my head that is wonderful news
I'm very proud of you
and you must be very proud of yourself I
am ma'am you know how you told me to
keep looking for the goals I had in my
life once I get home like to find the
things I look forward to I nodded well I
figured out what they are Coco came into
my life for a reason I have to take care
of him now good for you and I'm going to
apply for the working dog program in the
Marine Corps she added I figure once you
know what it is you love you might as
well do everything you can to fit it
into every part of your life I believe
that good doctors learn from their
patients every day but I never expected
that in the middle of the desert half a
world away a female sergeant in the
United States Marine Corps would define
a new cure for depression
thank you very much I believe that we
have time for a few questions if anyone
has them yes sir this is the second rule
ah excellent question how many in here
are mash fans I grew up watching it I
love it Matt rule number two came from
an episode of mash there's an episode
where Hawkeye meets a friend of his from
high school that is is going out to the
front lines and later the friend comes
back and and has been shot and needs
surgery and Hawkeye operates on him and
he loses him on the table
and he is distraught and Henry who is my
favorite character in all of mash comes
in and he says you know I don't know
much I only know what they taught me in
commanding officer school and they
taught us that there are two rules of
war rule number one is that young men
die and rule number two is the doctors
can't change rule number one mm-hmm
other questions
kind of big spirit what kinds of
experiences emotions did you go through
it's it's not too personal it's
something that now a couple years later
I feel like I've processed but you're
looking at part of the therapy process
connection after an experience like this
connection back with a world that's not
at war is intensely difficult it is it's
not as difficult as combat but it is
uniquely almost as difficult I think and
I think a lot of people experience this
that things out there while scary and
sometimes horrific and sometimes very
sad they had a very defined order and a
very set plan and we had blinders on and
it was it was quite easy to to not have
to deal with most of our grief loss fear
any of it for that matter because we had
a job to do and we were working seven
days a week 12 14 20 hours a day quite
frankly we were too tired so none of it
got dealt with and I know I'm just only
speaking for myself here but I think
that this is a theme I'm seeing with my
patients now as well that I think while
we're out there we're not paying
attention to anything that needs to be
processed and how could we we wouldn't
be able to function so we come home and
suddenly that's when all of it
surfaces so not only is there this
strange juxtaposition of a world at
peace in this world that we were just in
which is at war there's also a real
difficulty in my case at least with
connecting with people who didn't
understand it's a the movie Band of
Brothers is called that for a reason
there's this this feeling that it's very
very difficult to engage the people who
who weren't there because you walk a
fine line of disclosing too much that
that maybe a person doesn't want to hear
all this
or that maybe there's no way they could
ever understand so why even try why even
start to go there so it took many many
months of struggle with my husband and
and my children for me to try to find
the place where I could start to explain
and I had it easy my husband's a marine
I think of these spouses who have no
knowledge of the military it's a very
it's a very different difficult clash of
worlds I also had a really difficult
time going back to clinical practice
seeing people who were not combat vets
which I was at Naval Hospital
Jacksonville got pulled out of there by
myself to deploy with the San Diego unit
so got returned to Jacksonville a
hospital where no one had deployed to
Iraq and all my patients were not
dealing with any of this so it was it's
very difficult for me to find empathy
for what are very real problems there's
nothing nothing nothing to say that
their problems and the things that we're
upsetting them were not real but I had a
I I couldn't I couldn't sort of get out
of my you know you call that a problem
sensation it took me a long time to get
back to realizing that everyone's
problems are on a continuum and just
because someone isn't dying in your arms
doesn't mean it's not painful so it was
a long haul and writing the book
actually helped a tremendous amount yes
ma'am
thank you dogs do you have a dog I
always did grew up with one and had one
up until the point when I married my
husband who is not a dog person I would
have one in a heartbeat but he would not
so but I loved him yeah I think you're
right on as far as their even if you are
a dog person the therapeutic value of
having dogs they've certainly seen that
to be the case in with aging elderly
nursing homes now they have red pen sand
dogs and and for all kinds of handicaps
and I live on a farm and I have two dogs
and
I don't know what I I don't know how I
ever existed without them they're
awesome yeah it's a there they're
wonderful and such a strange yeah a
strange sort of unexpected gift the time
we had with those working dogs and it's
a woman I mean that that just turned her
around it clinically it did is a
wonderful story thank you thank you I
actually this is the Army Major the
veterinarian I used his real name
patients names are all changed but I
used his real name and it'd be
interesting to see if I couldn't find
him before I wrote the book but it'll be
interesting to see if he gets in touch
and says I didn't know that such a great
guy yes sir may be a little unfair
because you have a this current
experience but PTSD I think there's that
that it's kind of a new nomenclature
kind of a thing for a lot of us is the
experience that that results in that
different in your this current conflict
is it really different from kinds of
things that happen to now I'm at Korea
PTSD can be from any kind of trauma they
the key diagnostic factors mean that the
purse that include that the person has
to experience helplessness hopelessness
terror or somehow another sort of beyond
the realm of human experience feeling so
we see PTSD and rape survivors assault
survivors survivors of national natural
disasters combat it kind of has its own
slant you can imagine but no I I think
each conflict of course has its special
flavor sort of things that that people
say that they deal with I think the use
of children as combatants in this
conflict have been difficult for our
guys not knowing whether a child is
armed or not whether a child is going to
throw a grenade whether a child is going
to blow a whistle that leads somebody
else to pop it you know blow a grenade
or ie D some of those things are a
little bit unique possibly although I
understand it also happened in Vietnam
some somewhat but I so we we sort of
have certain things that are a little
different but no
I think overall it's the same they have
the same nightmares that Vietnam vets
World War two vets have the same same
symptoms yes ma'am I was surprised to
know this but it's actually already on
amazon.com and barnesandnoble.com for
pre-order which is surprised me but I
guess that's how they do it it's kind of
fun to see it though the Culver's
they're so new treatment modalities for
treating this syndrome then there were
you know 2530 years ago yes actually I'm
not sure if they're actually new or if
they were used in different things
before but yes there's there's probably
four or five really strongly
evidence-based treatments for PTSD now
and therapists these days who are taking
care of combat vets myself included are
getting trained in them so that we make
sure that we know that where we're
pulling from a very very strongly
supported base of treatments new
validation evidence for this particular
conflict are just being just the data is
just coming in now of course but widely
used in other types of trauma and other
combat so yes there's there's four or
five different types of treatments that
really work
because some people have to get back to
work thank you all very very much
Heidi cramps new book is rule number two
this event was hosted by the University
Club of Washington DC for more
information visit university club d.c
dot-com